Alma Guillermo Prieto what is looking
for history all about it's a book of
essays that I've written over the last
six years about the countries that
matter most to me and also the countries
that the United States is deeply
involved in or has been deeply involved
with or is about to become deeply
enmeshed with essentially that's what it
is
what's the derivation or the origin of
Guillermo Prieto huh my
great-great-great I may be missing a
great their grandfather was called
Guillermo Pietro and he was a very
popular poet in his day and a journalist
and a member of President Juarez's
cabinet and he saved twice his life once
which is where all the school children
learn he threw himself in front of the
firing squad and said los Balian
business a seaman brave people don't
assassinate and so the soldiers being
romantics themselves listen to this and
didn't assassinate what was this this
was in 1857 and ever since then some of
the family has carried his first and
last name is our last name it's
cumbersome it wasn't my idea where were
you born I was born in Mexico City and
why is it you speak almost perfect
English because when I was six years old
I was taken to Los Angeles and I spent
the next five years living there as a
little girl and then we returned my
mother and I to Mexico and I lived there
until I went to live in New York so you
know I always say that I'm a Mexican but
if I had to be a citizen of anywhere
else I'd be a citizen of Manhattan I
feel very much a New Yorker where's your
school I went to school at a school that
doesn't exist anymore it was called the
Walden school so you can guess a lot of
things from it by the name right we were
allowed to smoke in the classroom we all
wore blue jeans and sandals where was it
it was right off Central Park West on
the Upper West Side and it was you know
the ultimate kind of model for the
progressive school I was very happy
there and what what is that your college
or high school that was my high school
and then because partly I think this was
such a progressed
place you know I didn't go to college I
couldn't be bothered with that so I
didn't go to college why did you get
into writing oh because because I was
lucky because I was really lucky a
friend of my mother's an old friend of
my mother has had a publication about
Latin America in London it was well
known and well regarded the Latin
American news letters and when all hell
broke loose in the Quran WA nobody knew
where Nicaragua was nobody knew how to
pronounce that nobody knew how to spell
that
and I happen to speak English and I
happen to know John Reggie who was the
editor Latin America newsletters and he
said would I go and I said of course and
that's how it started the next day I was
writing for The Guardian for the very
same reason nobody in London and at the
Guardian had any correspondent anywhere
near in Nicaragua and from there it was
The Washington Post I spent four years
in Central America covering the various
conflicts there are you an opinion Asst
or are you a journalist um I'm a writer
I'm a writer who does a lot of reporting
I really learned the trade first at the
Guardian but a lot at the Washington
Post you know I I covered the Central
America Beach for the post as a stringer
then I came up here I worked on the
Metro desk I I learned that those sort
of tools of reporting I'm an efficient
good professional reporter but I also
write and so what I try to do is write
about places that I know that I care
about intensely and write about them in
a way that conveys the fact that I care
I I don't pretend to write a report you
know I write an essay I write something
that let has cost me some emotion and
that I hope will transmit some emotion
but I write it with the facts this book
has a number of articles in from the
past that you've written
where were they originally published
about half of them come out of the New
Yorker which is the place that I had
written most for over the last ten years
and about half of them come from the New
York
books which is another publication that
I feel very great admiration for I feel
very lucky to write for both of them and
they are both publications but will let
a writer kind of run with a topic and
that's a lot of fun and I hope it's fun
for the reader as well I'm gonna pull a
name out of the Miller book that I
wanted to ask you about because it
seemed to had a lot of personal
background is it a laid papa I lie
either father is caught by it was that
was close that was good what who was she
or who is she um oh I know you there
football was one of the founders of the
feminist movement in Mexico she was also
a very well brought up and genteel lady
who was born in Argentina and then I
think arrived in Guatemala at a very
early age and then had to move to Mexico
when there was a coup against the
President of what they mother that was
sponsored by the CIA back in 1954 you
may remember that and she was also very
good friend of my mother's again and she
then became very influenced perhaps by
her revolutionary children her her two
sons and her two daughters and when her
sons were one was kidnapped and the
other was murdered in Guatemala they had
joined the guerrilla movement in
Guatemala she felt the need to go down
as a warrior apparently with some
letters and she was also captured by the
government and she became one of those
people who were classified as
disappeared do you know what that means
it means when you're never heard from
again and so she was never heard from
again she was in her 60s and it was a
very strange and awful destiny for
someone like that to meet so yeah I I
think about her from time to time how
much of that goes on in Latin America
today I think that one of the things
that we can really all feel very happy
about is that the human rights situation
in Latin America has improved enormously
over the last 10 years enormous ly
enormous ly the the level of horror that
some of us had to cover as reporters
working in Latin America was pretty hard
to describe at points and it has changed
there is a difference largely thanks to
human rights activists in this country
and in Europe too who put pressure on
governments and and made them see that
it was not in their best interest to go
around murdering people recklessly and
torturing them and of course the
situation has improved for us for the
journalists as well the Committee to
Protect Journalists has been very
effective also in lobbying in that same
way you know journalists are not getting
killed in quite the same way they were
10 years ago
that's way down Colombia is one of the
countries which is still a problem for
journalists do you have a favorite of
all your essays um you know I'm kind of
fond of the story I wrote about Fidel
Castro and Pope John Paul the second
when the Pope goes to visit Fidel in
Havana that happened I guess in January
two years ago was it it's hot no it must
have been three years ago because I'll
tell you what happened in the course of
that and there that it was supposed to
be a kind of triumphal moment for a
female he had orchestrated very much to
call the world's attention to Cuba to
its flight and to the Pope's declaration
against the US economic embargo of Cuba
and thousands of journalists went down
to Cuba for that meeting and do you
remember what happened I do very much
Monica Lewinsky happened right in the
middle and everybody left Cuba and Fidel
was left alone with a coke Pope which
was a good company but I don't think it
was quite what he expected anyway that
story was written with that visit as the
central point but it was also the
occasion the opportunity for me to go
back to a place that I knew relatively
well and hadn't been back to for many
years and and so it is a little bit of a
walk down memory lane the revolutionary
cube I remembered the
had dismal place I saw the perplexity of
Cubans themselves about their own future
about what their leader was doing that
this man this Catholic when they had
been brought up to believe that all
religion was a form of evil it was an
interesting moment it was very
interesting for me I had a good time
there despite myself and I enjoyed
writing about it so I I'm fond of that
story what has been Fidel Castro's
impact on the people of Cuba
oh well whenever anybody is in power for
40 years the impact it is so it takes
place on so many levels
you know it's an impact on how you say
good morning in school to the teacher
it's an impact on how you stand in line
for your rations for 40 years
week after week to get the groceries
that you will eat it's an impact on how
your see your place in the world as well
I think that for so many Cubans Fidel
was a source of pride in being Cuban
certainly during the first ten years of
revolution perhaps even during the first
twenty you know if you were a Cuban you
were somebody you weren't some Honduran
lost in the middle of history without a
role to play you might be in a very
small island in a very small country but
you were a challenge to the greatest
power in the world you could feel proud
of that I think that had enormous weight
but then you know it's 20 years and then
it's 30 and then it's 40 and by god
you're still standing in line for
rations and you still can't get enough
soap or toilet paper and your whole life
has been spent under the Revolution I
think that the temptation to feel that
your entire life has been wasted must be
very great for a lot of Cubans why have
I don't know what modifier I want to use
but say so many American journalists
gone down there over the years and
fallen in love with Fidel Castro because
he is enormous Lee
is Matic I mean we all know better than
to fall in love but we all fall in love
he was a very beautiful man physically
he had enormous presence the enormous
command he had these you know beautiful
hands that he gestured with he had that
funny silvery papery voice that didn't
seem threatening and he was speaking for
truth and justice I mean you know what
could be won for that he certainly
thought so do you think he was uh yes I
think he was speaking for truth and
justice the only problem is he didn't
know how to bring it about and I think
that he committed a mistake that is not
his alone I think in Latin America over
the centuries we have had an enormous
fondness and weakness for heroes the
kind of hero who gets killed the kind of
hero who is willing to give his life for
a cause and that's the only kind of
people we trust and Fievel showed that
he was willing to give his life for a
cause and that to that degree
he was absolute and he was absolutely
sincere and that's our our weakness I
know you know as I get older I tend to
like the kind of small hero much more I
keep saying they were the one who works
out sewage problems the one who thinks
about how to improve the fat content in
milk and get it distributed on time but
that's not very exciting he asked you
about something I could be right about
Subcomandante Marcos yes another
charismatic leader where where is he you
were very good at producing this kind of
person he's back in Chiapas um I think
he's probably back in Chiapas trying to
figure out his fate where is Jeff Chavez
is in the southernmost part of Mexico
and Mexico as you travel down it from
the US border it gets progressively more
beautiful and progressively poorer and
Chiapas is about as beautiful and as
poor as you can get it has very high
hills not quite mountains it has great
big rivers it produces
some very significant portion of the
National Electricity in its dams and it
has I think the largest population of
indigenous people in Mexico the Maya
Indians in their various language groups
there's seven eight-nine
language maya language group spoken in
Chiapas and it was here that seven years
ago through commandante Marcos became
known because he led this great Indian
rebellion that it was the shot that was
not heard around the world or the unshot
that was heard around the world because
there really wasn't much of a battle
even though they call themselves the
Zapatista National Liberation Army they
didn't have guns they didn't know how to
take on the army and so there was a
ceasefire 12 days after that small
battle began and ended and ever since
then for the last six or seven years I
think soup command anthem Marcos and his
community of rebels have been trying to
figure out what comes next and you met
him by the way oh yes I talked to him at
great length and great length one
evening at greater length and I might
have liked because I was falling asleep
I don't have his capacity to stay awake
all night this was in about seven hours
further south from san cristobol which
is the very beautiful town that is sort
of the center for these Maya communities
it was in a place it wasn't not really
that which is where he tends to hang out
lately where was it it was called Bravo
Baca Jana it was just a very very small
village and it had a school building and
what was really sad about that school
building is that it wasn't occupied by
students because there were never any
teachers for these kids who who lived in
about as great miseries that you can
find in Latin America I remember very
clearly we spent two days there I spent
almost three days there waiting for soup
commandante marcos to show up much the
same way one waits for the event to show
up for the interview it never happens
but in his case Michael showed up he
showed up at one o'clock in the morning
how old is he he's must be 42 now so
seven years ago he
in his mid-thirties yeah he was a junkie
life he's um well I can't tell you what
he looks like because of course he wears
the ski mask over his head and his face
all the time and so all you can see are
his eyes which happened to be very
beautiful I'm sure he knows that to
himself
you know why does he wear the mask well
if they weren't so beautiful maybe he'd
wear the mask around his mouth you know
but he wears it around the eyes to set
off these eyes which were nice and so
that nobody would recognize him and
place him why didn't he want anybody
recognize and replace him it now occurs
to me that probably because if he were
recognized and placed by the
intelligence services then he would be
placed in the middle of a very
traditional Orthodox guerilla movement
that existed in Mexico from 19 from the
mid 70s on and which the southeast the
National Liberation Army grew out of and
I think probably Marcos realized that
this would not generate more sympathy
for the Maya cause but would rather make
people a little distrustful of him so he
covered up his identity with a mask and
anyway we love masks you know because
theatrical so how important is he to
Mexico I think he was very important I
think that when he first stepped out to
the front of this movement and said this
is why we're fighting and this is who we
are and you the rest of Mexicans have
been acting as if we were a rich and
powerful country and you've been going
on a spending spree and you've been
flirting with the first world but here
we are and we're dirt poor and this is a
dirt poor country and there's ten
million of us Indians and you are not
paying attention I think that was
terribly important for Mexico here I
think he did something quite wonderful
what's he doing man he's trying to
figure out how not to fade from the
limelight
you know Mexicans felt very good about
saying yes we have an Indian population
yes we love you yes we want to support
you yes we will come out on the streets
in March for you and we don't want you
killed but again it's this problem of
time and I think it's also
problem of our increasingly shorter
attention spans you know one two three
four five years go by and then Markos
gets a little boring and well we've
heard enough about the Indians already
let's change the subject and so now that
he had his very important visit to
Mexico City after seven years of hiding
in this little village in in the former
lacan Don jungle and addressing Congress
he take his mask Oh No
and and he didn't address Congress one
of the militant women from the
Zapatistas addressed Congress and it was
a very powerful and moving speech when
did he do this this was two months this
was in February it was towards the end
of February that they came to Mexico
City and then two weeks later I think
they were all exhausted by this monster
that exactly exhausts and devours us all
at a city of 20 million people they were
fading from the first page from the
front page of newspapers even Lin and
they decided to go back to chant lesson
and that's where they are now I think
there will be peace negotiations between
the zapatistas and the government and I
think the outcome will be of some
benefit to the Maya communities it won't
solve all the problems there are very
difficult problems and then what happens
to my close I don't know it's a good
question he writes very well maybe he'll
become a reporter I want to ask you
about a couple of statistics I think I
read that you said there about 95
million people in Mexico that's right
close to 100 million according to the
latest census and about 45 million of
them are poverty-stricken if that's the
word well below the official poverty
level by Mexican standards which are not
us standards what does that mean you
want to know well then one more
statistic I think I'd probably read this
wrong the only three million people pay
taxes only let's see do you do the math
for me if only ten percent after many
years of trying to reform taxes at this
stage according to the latest report
which is put out by the Mexican
government early this year ten percent
of the entire population their taxes
cover
the entire government budget every ten
million people that's ten million people
that sounds high to me maybe there is a
statistic where you said they've gone
from 2 to 3 million people paid all the
taxes yeah I remember that and that was
about seven years ago
so it seems high to me that it would
have gone up by so much it may be that
the figure of ten percent includes the
value-added tax I think that's probably
would have come too and everybody pays
that and and well everybody who can
afford certain kind of manufactured
products pays that so this no matter how
you balance it out the figure is still
very very small a very large country
with very poor people with a government
on a very small budget if you're meeting
an American for the first time and you
sense early on that they know nothing
about Mexico and how often does that
happen
oh every time I come to this country but
you sense that they want to know hmm
what do you tell them about Mexico that
they should know I mean right up front
ah well I tell them that we don't have a
military regime which a lot of people
seem to think that we do I tell them
that we just have had elections last
year and that for the first time in more
than 70 years there is a president who
is not from the official party there
isn't the official party is now in
opposition um I tell them that we watch
a lot of TV and a lot of us programming
and that we're probably more familiar
with the United States than most people
in the United States are with us you
know we wear Nikes and gap and go to
Hollywood movies and eat it McDonald's
and get our cars fixed it's something
that this is all after NAFTA I always
feel good
Midas yes by this muffler Midas muffler
that's where we go so I think we know a
lot more about this culture and of
course millions of us cross the border
to work in US homes and garden
in factories and carpentry shops and
restaurants and if you go to a
restaurant pretty much anywhere in the
United States with chances are that the
dishes will be washed by Mexican you
write a lot about other places besides
make sure we can come back to Mexico but
you've got some again some personal
stories you lead off the book with I
guess you would say
Ava Peron Eva Peron VP Evita yeah why do
you lead your book off with um actually
that was just chronology is it am I am i
right Ava yeah no I knew if something
wasn't she was he was something she was
a self-made woman and I think that a
large part of her attraction is that she
invented herself and we're always very
admiring of and maybe even jealous of
women who invent themselves who go from
brunette to blonde as she did who go
from dirt poor back in the sticks a
country girl to gold LeMay you know on
the arm of some tuxedo person in France
she's at a cocktail reception in France
and in that gold on a dress that's not
one wrong
that's not one bit on it no it's not no
it's her escort for the evening in
France somewhere she she was the most
influential woman in Latin America
probably and she was the wife of one fed
on who rose to power in Argentina in the
40s and became the first of the great
populist can you tell us that she died
on July the 26th 1952 and she was 33
years old
mm-hmm like and she was all that and
only 33 and only 33 and she didn't even
start until she was 19 which is when she
first met one bit on she was in a hurry
I think that like so many of our heroes
she courted death eventually she knew
she was going to die when she found out
that she had cancer she didn't want to
have an operation because she said she
was too busy and when she died of course
she became a myth because if you're
going to be a meth or want to be a math
you'd better die young
and she did if she was beautiful she was
young she was powerful and she had the
kind of personality that really projects
itself into history she took you know
lice-infested young street children back
to the presidential palace with her and
bathed them herself she would take off
her diamonds and give them to poor
people she would also at a reception
with very wealthy people full of
diamonds would hint that she very much
would like the diamond necklace one of
the guests was wearing so it worked both
ways but she was intense she she was
fully alive and so I think she became
one of the great miss well we know she
became one of aggressiveness Madonna was
besotted with her and fought hard to
play her in the movie so I I think one
of the things that we do is produce
heroes not only for our own consumption
but certainly for a world consumption in
jail was a world figure you know Ajay is
still being worn on t-shirts around the
world and and he's become a sort of logo
but at the end of your piece on David
Peron you write about Juan Peron second
wife and first of all how long was he
how long was he in power in Argentina oh
let's see
he's overthrown in 44 and then he god
I'm so bad on date you shouldn't ask me
this because I doesn't matter he came
back again though well he came back
again 20 years later he came back in
1973 I think he's supposed to last time
in 1954 he comes back in 1973 so that's
almost 20 years and that by then ever of
course is long gone long dead she died
while he was still in power and he was
overthrown shortly thereafter partly
because she gave him the energy that he
needed to to stay in power and to fend
off the plots and counter plots and when
he came back he was married for a second
time yes to ISA bolita
but in that mixed of all that what I
want you to talk about is what they did
with that Peron ever perón's body
they've preserved it it one fit on it
had a very famous embalmer brought in
from from Spain and the body apparently
was a masterpiece of embalming the the
hair well what happened immediately
before ever died you have to remember is
that she decided that red nails would
not look good on a corpse and so at the
very last minute she asked to have her
red manicure changed to a natural
manicure which she felt would just be
more tasteful and she was right of
course and then she was in bombed she
was beautifully combed her hair was
bleached one last time and combed and
she was preserved and then the body
after villain was overthrown the body
got taken to Europe and the great
authority on this is Tomas Eloy Martinez
the novelist who's written two novels
one was called the novel of Bataan and
the other one was called Saint Evita and
in it he chronicles the embalmed bodies
wanderings from Italy to Spain to
Amsterdam and then back to Spain again
when the Argentine military decides it
can no longer control Argentina they
want bit on to come back and as a peace
offering they say here have the body and
so the corpse was returned in Madrid to
one fit on the next chapter of this
story I find almost impossible to
believe on the other hand I have no
reason to distrust what my friend Tomas
aloy Martinez has investigated the next
chapter is that it on second wife Maria
Ave Marias de loarre
ISA bolita she was known fed on who was
a former cabaret dancer and who didn't
look like a former cabaret dancer she
looked like a former schoolmarm it was
very strange but she was a former
cabaret dancer and she did have a kind
of addiction to spiritual advisors and
sorcerers and so when they don't married
her he also ended up marrying in a way
Isabella the spiritual adviser who was a
warlock
called Jose Lopez Vega and look the
traitor lifts with him and Madrid and he
and he savvy Lita decided that the thing
to do was to have a sabelli tougher on
second wife lie on top of the coffin of
Evita while Lopez raiga performed a
ritual that would transmute a Vitas soul
into ISA Benitez body I don't think it
worked because it's a bolita never had a
shred of evidence magnetism charm
passion commitment but when it on any
sub elite they returned to Buenos Aires
the end of the story is they don't died
shortly after he became president ISA
bolita who had run for vice president on
Barone's ticket became the president of
Argentina and Lopez ray the warlock
became the real Rasputin and I used that
comparison very advisedly because he
ruled in a fiendish manner he set up the
death squads and he's a bolita head
Evita brought back to Argentina where
she was finally buried but there's a
little caveat on that one in 1987 you
say vandals broke open the tomb in order
to saw off Tyrone's hand his hand his
hands they were not buried together 1/3
on I think in the end had become a
little resentful of Eva she was so
popular she was so much more loved than
he was and he never wanted to be buried
in the same tomb with her so she was
buried in her family crypt he was buried
in his own crypt and one of the great
mysteries is why someone would it was
you know it's not just any tomb they
were marble plaques it's part of a
monument and take out the body and sawed
off the dead man's hands and then put
the body back in why would somebody do
that it's been speculated that because
the fingerprints on the hands were the
identifying mechanisms and the password
as it were for the secret bank accounts
that the padrone's had in
transits you know one guess how much of
your time do you spend in Mexico City um
I spent most of my time in Mexico City I
also spend a lot of time outside of
Mexico City in a very small town where I
really learn more about what's happening
in the mexico profundo let's say one of
the things that I find out is happening
is that everybody's leading for the
United States how any way they can get
here why why because the most that
somebody in Mexico City will get paid
for a job in construction there's a
hundred pesos a day which instruments do
to ten dollars nine dollars in change a
day and you come here and I don't even
know what you get for washing dishes but
it's not nine dollars a day and so
people will you know it works like a
chain somebody will come from village X
and then they'll send for the brother
and then they'll send for the sister and
then they'll send for the brother-in-law
and they'll send for the wife of the
brother-in-law everybody sharing a very
small house or an apartment working in
shifts and sending money back to the
family it's good for the United States
um I I don't feel qualified trans for
that question what I wonder is what
would happen in California say if all
the Mexicans left from one day to the
next who would do what Americans like to
call the dirty work
I don't think Mexico see it as dirty
work at all they see it is a good honest
living and they'd see it as doing work
that nobody else wants and they see it
as keeping their families alive and
improving their future the future of
their children which they see is a
fundamental duty why do you said earlier
that you didn't go to college by the way
do you think you missed anything yeah
sure I missed four years of having well
I probably would have had to work while
I went to college but it still it's four
years I think of freedom four years when
you get to learn for the pure pleasure
of it four years of thinking about ideas
about what other people did of
admiring you know people who came before
us and created the world we know I miss
that very much I think it would have I
think I made a silly mistake yes but how
did you get places like the New York
Review of Books and the New Yorker
magazine and others to appreciate your
writing I mean where did you teach
yourself how to write you having help
along the way I read a lot I read a lot
and both of my parents I think would
have wanted to be writers it's funny how
one ends up doing the things that but
parents perhaps the dreams of parents
couldn't fulfill I know that my mother
would have been beyond herself to have
had a story published in am a New Yorker
so are they gone both of yes and what
did they do for a living um they worked
in public relations and in in Mexico
mostly here my mother worked in the
States sometimes as a secretary and then
you know she put herself through college
and worked in in social programs around
NYU mostly and then moved back to Mexico
where she worked with administering a
kind of arts and culture program for the
Social Security Institute so she was a
big reader she loved to read I love to
read I I grew up reading do you read
better in English or in Spanish I think
both I really think that I'm a bilingual
reader about a thinker um I don't know
I'm trying to find that out you know I
write a food column now in in Spanish
for a monthly magazine in Mexico and I
started doing that partly because I love
food and I love everything involved with
food I love the fun of it I love
restaurants I love cooking although I
don't cook very much I love kitchens but
also because I thought it would be a
good way to try to work on Spanish again
and to pick up my language where I left
off and and try to see if I had an
instrument there you know aligned which
is an instrument and so I've been
working on that kind of polishing it
it and seeing what will happen to it I
like it it certainly comes from a
different place
talking in one language and talking in
another I think inevitably produce two
different personalities as far as I've
seen in other people I assume it does
the same thing you ever checked yourself
to see what language three men yeah and
in fact I dream in whatever language I'm
living in so that you know after six
months of being in the States I started
dreaming in English again and when I
moved back to Mexico after a few months
I started dreaming in Spanish again you
know of all the pieces you've written
for an American audience which one's
gotten the most reaction um I think in
very different ways I wrote a series
well I wrote a couple of stories for The
New Yorker way back when about the
modernization of Mexico under NAFTA and
it was a story ostensibly about
mariachis and the death of mariachi
music in Mexico and a lot of people
responded to that because what do you
know about Mexico you know that there is
my auntie's there right and maybe you
even gone there as a tourist and you've
been and Guddi Bundy Plaza and you've
had a few tequilas and hooked it up and
listen to mariachi music you never did
that it's fun you should I like mariachi
music but what happened to it is it gone
yes it's going it's going because first
of all pop music from the states is
taking over more and more and more I
think the great Mexican cuisine is dying
because there are fast foods now
competing them because there are super
markets and supermarkets can't afford to
keep in stock a lot of these very
perishable products that are used for
fine mexican cooking women are working
and real Mexican cooking requires
enormous amounts of time so the story
was about all those changes and what it
meant to be Mexican and what it meant to
be modern and if you could feel Mexican
and feel modern at the same time which i
think is a debate that we have with
ourselves constantly and haven't solved
by any means so that was a story that
got a lot of response and that people
tend to remember and then last year I
did for The New York Review of Books a
series of three articles about Colombia
and how that's in here they're all in
there yeah yeah no it's actually what I
want to ask you about next is a Columbia
station first of all if you've seen the
recent figures on how much foreign aid
goes to Columbia you know I think for
fiscal year 2000 2001 a billion has
already been allocated out of the three
billion plus that puts it right up there
near right after Israel and Egypt that's
exactly what it puts it yeah in the
second Jordan yeah why why do we give
that much money to Columbia ah because
when you don't know what to do about a
problem you throw money at and I think
is one of the good reasons because the
money was there because I think probably
the Clinton administration thought that
it would look good and that nobody in
their right mind would say well don't
give money to the drug war the drug war
is a big problem I think it's a disaster
but that's my opinion
who was Rosa hmm Joseph was the name I
gave a woman I met just after she had
been detained I was lucky enough to find
out that she was being held in and not
imprisoned as she was being detained
prior to her trial she was a woman maybe
a little younger than me who started out
as a revolutionary and ended up as a
right-wing paramilitary and who was
happy to tell me how the paramilitaries
butchered people in order to keep the
revolutionaries away and to me she was a
way of understanding the terrible mess
that Colombia has become the the
enormous difficulty of trying to
understand that the enormous difficulty
of trying to live in the middle of this
series of intertwined conflicts that
here in the United States is called a
war as if there were only one war and
and how to keep your balance and place
yourself and be a participant of that
history this woman you know by rights I
should have been horrified by her and I
was she she always said that she didn't
participate directly in any of the
political violence he had never murdered
anyone but I think a lot of her role was
to in her community work with the
villages and
campesinos the peasants was to justify
these massacres and to say that this was
the only way to fight for justice in
Colombia I was horrified but at the same
time I could understand her perplexity
at having been born the child of war
which she was and and not finding any
path for herself anyway to be in the
world that didn't involve violence there
there's one thing that got my attention
when he talked and talked about her
being tortured and am I using pliers and
pulling off her teeth actually if you
want to be specific about it what they
did was they took the pliers and they
broke off her teeth so that they they
were all broken at the root they weren't
pulled out but broken and that's why she
could have caps put on them and that's
why she showed me that all of her teeth
had cats why were they doing and then
they jumped on her stomach and then they
made her stand all night while she was
bleeding and then they let her go
they were glue was doing that well this
is the interesting thing she was
kidnapped at the time that she was still
working with the left-wing guerrillas
and apparently they had invaded the
guerrillas and the campesinos that the
guerrillas were organizing had invaded
of ranch owned by somebody with close
ties to the paramilitary and this was a
bad mistake in Colombia you should
always try to find out who you're
kidnapping and or whose land you're
invading because if you're kidnapping a
drug trafficker or if you're invading a
paramilitaries land then you're in for
real trouble let me stop because I'm a
little confused
what's a right-wing guerilla right-wing
guerilla is a paramilitary what's a
paramilitary a paramilitary somebody who
fights the left-wing guerrillas
what's the left-wing rule a left-wing go
really somebody who belongs to an
organization that by now is 30 or 40
years old there are several guerrilla
groups in Colombia not just one and they
more or less adhere to a Maoist or a
traditional Cuban approach to revolution
which is that you have a guerrilla group
and then the whole country spontaneously
rise
and then you have socialism the
right-wing paramilitaries also use
weapons also live in the mountains but
they're trying to fight the left-wing
guerrillas for who who are they fighting
for well they're fighting very often in
alliance with the government army or
with sectors of the government army who
are we funding the United States is
providing military assistance to the
government army and to the government
police force which also is closely
aligned in many cases in many specific
areas of the country with the right-wing
paramilitaries Praetorian purpose is to
the left wing and the right wing mullah
grows all make the same amount of money
probably the right-wing paramilitaries
have better salaries at this stage
because they're the organization is
smaller where do they get the money for
these salaries you might well ask well
the way that most of them get money is
from taxes that they levy on the drug
traffickers who transport coca leaf
through the territories of BAE control
how do they levy those taxes through
agreements they say we will provide
protection for you to transport this
truckload of coca leaf or this speedboat
load of coca paste and we will see to it
that if the army interferes with you we
interfere with the army or simply we
will provide security so that you travel
through an army free zone or of
government vigilance free zone and in
exchange for this you the drug
traffickers will pay us the guerrillas
or us the paramilitaries I believe it's
5% of the value of what you are
transporting we don't we're funding the
military which also is helping to fund
the paramilitary which very often
provides according to Human Rights Watch
according to various NGOs and according
to general knowledge very often the
military will provide for example
intelligence in this village there are x
y&z families who collaborate with the
left-wing guerrillas why don't you go
get them who's funding the left the left
is being funded primarily by
the drug traffickers who provide this
tax money and that's why the gorillas in
Colombia unlike the gorillas anywhere
else in Latin America have been able to
survive for 40 years because they have a
hard solid source of income so why do
you say we're doing the wrong thing
well because it seems to me that you're
a little confused by this panorama that
I've just tried to explain as simply as
possible and you should be because it's
a confusing panorama because there are
no absolutes there are no good and bad
sides there's not even one war with two
sides to it there and it's not a civil
war it is a series of conflicts
festering conflicts forty-year-old
conflicts that nobody understands that
nobody can find the little thread that
will untie it - and it seems to me that
throwing money at a conflict like this
is probably useless and very possibly
dangerous and how far into all of us did
you travel to and where did you go um
I've known Colombia for many years now I
first went there in 1973 I went back
there in 1986 I lived there for four
years from 1988 to 9 1988 to 1992 which
was at the height of the drug violence
and in 86 I actually took a very
remarkable and beautiful journey to the
guerrillas base camp which as it turned
out after these five miserable strenuous
arduous days partly on foot and partly
on horseback it turned out we'd only
traveled 80 miles from the capital which
gives you an idea of how difficult it is
you know you have a guerrilla group that
won't advance on the capital but that
had its permanent home base less than a
hundred miles away that's where we went
to it was in the foothills of the Amazon
basin why would they let you go there
because at that time they were
interested in getting some press
attention and so three of us went I
actually was a hanger-on there were two
Colombian journalists who had bargained
for this trip for a year and then I
showed up and said hi I'm Newsweek I'm
music I was working for Newsweek at the
time can I tag along on this trip and
the guerrilla said
you know we could use some us attention
as well and as it happened the story
never ran because nobody thought
Colombia was very interesting for years
I don't think you know two years ago if
anybody really knew where Colombia was
on the map so that story never been even
though I was able to interview the man
who even then was the world's oldest
living gorilla and his sidekick the
cofounders of the Colombian
Revolutionary Armed Forces what was his
name the founder and kind of
intellectual leader was named Rocco what
he knows he since died and the man who
is still the leader of the FARC and who
is still around today and who now really
is the world's oldest living gorilla
because I think he's 70 is a man whose
pseudonym is Manuel Marulanda Valles and
whose nickname Lee he's known by is Dido
fijo which means sure shot did the
Colombians by the way use the drugs
themselves down there increasingly yes
because one of the things that the drug
trade has done and this is a problem not
only in Colombia but in Buenos Aires and
in Rio and in Mexico is to make drugs
available possibly even below cost
outside of high schools and outside of
junior high schools middle schools and
even in some places outside of great
schools to to get themselves a local
market
so yes drugs are increasingly being used
how many American troops or aids or
unseen down there I I couldn't tell you
the latest figures there are no troops
according to the aid packages it has
been formulated the aid will go
primarily in weapons and equipment for
the military and the police and some for
the justice system which is desperate
the justice system really needs shoring
up judges get assassinated in Colombia
routinely and they don't even have a
bulletproof vest but most of the money
is going for guns and radar equipment
stuff like that and there are contract
employees of both the State Department
and the Pentagon who provide military
advice
supervision and I think the ceiling on
that is 500 but I'm not sure that's a
hard ceiling yeah we better close off on
Rosa we didn't finish the story on Rosa
yeah
so where did where did Rose I end up
alright so Rosa is working for the
left-wing guerrillas and she and her
friends have invaded a branch and the
ranch belongs to a paramilitary that is
a right-wing guerrilla and this man is
very annoyed and to express his
annoyance he has Rosa kidnapped and
brought to him and tortured and while he
is there he has somebody called
avoidable the fat man do all these
atrocious things to her and perhaps she
also speculated with me because she
didn't talk and didn't give any
information about her comrades in the
end these right-wing paramilitaries
admired her courage which also happens
among all of these kind of gung-ho you
know people with guns and they let her
go and one would have thought that her
reaction would be to get out of that
life altogether to listen to her parents
to move somewhere else or maybe even to
become more vehemently involved with her
own left-wing guerrilla cause instead of
which she crossed over it to the other
side she joined the right-wing
guerrillas which is how I met her she
just been arrested it's part of a sweep
operation okay you say there are 21
nations in Latin America yes if I
counted right don't ever quote me on
numbers I have to do a gun to each time
we didn't he didn't count places like
senator Mingo and all that I think I
probably did this well they're more than
21 this is are they're terrible I always
get it wrong and it defends they yeah I
mean I just went through all there's
probably 25 or so really Sara diamond
well we don't have time to do this right
now but the point is I want to ask you
about of all the countries south of us
yeah south of the United States which
one you think has the most promise based
on what you've seen in the last
years I think they all do I don't think
there is a basket-case among them is
there one that stars out of all that
well no I think Mexico for obvious
reasons should be and is tremendously
important to the United States not
important enough but but it is you know
the United States
what 2nd largest trading partner in
Canada yeah after Canada it shares an
enormous border it has a significant
percentage of its population working
here in this country which is by the way
a way of providing economic stability to
Mexico which is important to the United
States there's that to be said for it
too
but you have countries like Brazil which
sometimes doesn't like to consider
itself as part of Latin America you know
it's so much different cheese but
they're not so different during their
part of Latin America which is a huge
country with enormous potential in terms
of Natural Resources human resources
creativity than just the sheer amount of
intelligence of the inhabitants of a
country that is so poor and so good at
surviving Argentina which is
tremendously sophisticated and and
productive I don't see a basket case you
know it's it's a rich and powerful
region and it's full of unmet
expectations but also of hope the most
vigorous democracy of all I think at
this point probably Mexico because it's
just trying to figure out how this thing
is done and so it's exciting right now
yeah we only have a couple minutes left
and I want to ask you about che che
Guevara why did you write about him
because he was so important to so many
of us and because he was the ultimate
hero who only wants to die and because
in my own process of thinking about
Latin America I thought it's time to
write about these people who only want
to die so that maybe we can exercise
them and maybe we can start thinking
about the people who want to live where
was he from he was from Argentina he
helped female come to power in
Chuba he was a tremendously skillful
military fighter and strategist he died
in Bolivia after a manhunt in which he
and all his followers nearly starved to
death and were finally killed he died in
1967 that's the one did he ever is most
one gave his biggest impact I think the
moment he died because again by dying he
became a hero and he became somebody to
emulate and so many so many so many
Latin Americans did including my
mother's friend Ally Eva Papa think that
the only way to live a worthy life was
to offer their life instead of trying to
live another day and do things a little
bit better
a couple of things you mentioned that
Diaries came out in 1995 The Motorcycle
Diaries yeah what did you learn fry
those well The Motorcycle Diaries he
wrote when he was a very young man
taking his first trip from Buenos Aires
where he lived all the way up to
Venezuela with his friend on motorcycle
I learned that this man who became so
enamored of death was once a lively
funny jokey intellectually curious young
man who really loved Latin America and
who somehow at the end of that trip
became convinced that jokes were not
funny you know I have a video where he's
telling the factory workers who were
laughing at something and he says why
are you laughing why are you laughing
this is serious I was intrigued by the
process of losing the joyful part of
himself and becoming this termagant say
a couple quirky things he refused to
bathe and tie his shoelaces that's right
and he was very proud of the fact that
when he was still a teenager his
schoolmates called him tential which
means Pig and that's how he used to sign
his letters
why is he here oh because he died to
redeem us you think he did I think
that's what he was trying to do yes I
don't think he did but that's what he
was trying to do he was trying to be
like Christ he was trying to offer
himself up to sacrifice so that others
could live a better life is he still
revered today yes by many absolutely I I
don't think that you will find that many
young latin americans in university
who don't think that he is someone to to
admire and perhaps follow when you write
where do you do it
I write it well that doesn't really
matter hotel rooms for example are good
places for me to write because they are
so free of associations I have to get
myself into my sort of tedius sweat
pants and t-shirt and I do it on a
computer now amazingly enough I never
could use a typewriter because the noise
wrote me crazy the noise drove me crazy
but I used to use a notebook now I use a
computer because it doesn't make that
much noise are you better on deadline or
when you have a lot of time who was it
it maybe was on your program somebody
came out I think from the Washington
Post who had this wonderful quote a
journalist is somebody who when you give
them more time writes worse that's it
right here that's often say well I still
laugh at it because I thought well
there's a definition for me to pay
attention to
now you better win it you got somebody
says you got two hours get this in I
suspect we all are yeah but we all dream
of you know a great novel that we will
write something when we have timeline
it's probably not happening
what's it next for you ah I have a
horrible suspicion that Columbia is
going to be next for a long time because
I think it's just a mess we're involved
in our guest has been Almaguer mo Prieto
and here's what her book looks like a
series of articles written over the last
several years looking for history thank
you very much thank you